All right--so if you did this right, you would realize that what you need to do
to compute an expected value the sum of the overall values that it can take on
the probability of that value times the value itself.
So what that amounts to is summing overall the pairs w and x that are neighbors to v.
We sum whether they're either connected or they're not connected
and that's represented by the c[wx] thing and we need to multiply that by the probability
that we picked that particular w and x.
Well of all the w and x's are picked uniformly at random
and the number of different pairings of them is the degree of v
times the degree of v-1 divided by 2.
That's the number of different ways you can pair up a set of size dv.
The reciprocal of that is now the probability that we picked any particular pair.
But this is independent of c[wx] so really we can move this out front
and just do it as 2 times the degree times the degree minus 1
times whether or not the two nodes are connected.
And all that summed up for all of the w and x.
But the thing that I would like you to realize is this is exactly this.
So the expected value of randomly choosing a pair and checking if they're connected
is the same as actually computing this particular piece
of the clustering coefficient formula and the same trick works
in terms of the number of the vertices.
So if the vertex is chosen at random and then this quantity is evaluated for that vertex
the expected value of that is exactly the clustering coefficient.
So what that means is we can iterate this particular expression that I put braces around
and average that and if we did that forever, if we did that infinitely often,
it would be exactly the expected value, which would be exactly the clustering coefficient.
But since we can't do it forever, we'll run it for a certain
amount of time and we'll hope that it gets close.
Let me show you how it gets close over time.